- Hi, welcome to Hell!
More people tell you, go to hell.
Here, we welcome you.
- I'm in Hell and I did it all
without any tech from 2019.
(typing)
Why the hell did I end up in Hell?
Oh well, it's actually quite simple.
As the clock nears 2020,
I've been thinking a lot
about how much the smartphone
has changed the world and
us, in the last decade.
So, I challenged myself to
live with just 2010 tech
for 24 hours.
Does this not even have maps on it?
I asked my producer,
Kenny for some suggestions
on where to go.
- I think you should go to Hell, Michigan.
I grew up near there.
- [Narrator] And so, we got to packing.
I gathered a bunch of
gadgets I used in 2010.
You hear that?
Yeah, I'm bringing this.
My BlackBerry Bold 9700,
a Zune HD, a Flip Mino HD,
a Cannon point and shoot,
and a Garmin Nuvi for GPS.
All of them surprisingly worked
after I charged up the batteries.
Okay, I am putting this iPhone
in this drawer at my house,
and I'm leaving it here for
the next 24 hours or so.
Challenge one, get to Hell.
(jazz music)
And took off for the
airport to begin a series
of four challenges Kenny
had designed for me.
Hell, it turns out, is a small township
about 60 miles out of Detroit.
That meant, a flight, a drive
to stay at a hotel nearby,
and then another drive to Hell.
The flight part was easier than I thought.
Look at all these people on their phones.
(accordion music)
No ticket on my phone,
nothing to really do while
killing time in line.
This is Brick Breaker.
It's so good.
I was so good at this.
No streaming music or movies.
I really enjoyed using my Zune HD.
Now we must get off the flight.
We just landed in Detroit.
Solid G3 service here.
It's 21 degrees fahrenheit right now.
The driving part, not as easy.
- [Man] All right, so
what's going on here?
- [Narrator] No GPS.
It thinks we are in Wisconsin.
We're not in Wisconsin.
These are in Wisconsin still.
Turns out that Garmin
didn't have the latest software update.
Which needs to be downloaded
on a Windows computer
to reach the damn satellites.
So I went back to 2000.
But it looks like we've
gotta take 94 out of Detroit.
Ah, Howell!
The maps got me close,
but not close enough.
I had to call the hotel for directions.
- [Woman On Phone] We're
just a couple exits down.
- I'm so happy right now.
The Holiday Inn Express in
Howell, which is close to Hell.
Tomorrow we will go to Hell.
I asked the concierge to
print me out directions
from Howell to Hell.
(trunk slams)
(rock music)
Do you know how to get to Hell?
- Just past the high
school on Darwin road.
(rock music)
- I have been looking for
Darwin for quite a long time.
- Okay, so that's gonna
be down here on your left.
- Get ice here before Hell freezes over.
This is it.
Look.
Challenge complete.
Challenge two.
Post a Selfie on Instagram.
I really would like my
head to block the pure.
Try this again.
Nope.
Okay.
(beep)
(growls)
My Selfie game was not good in 2010.
Okay, now how to get these
photos on to Instagram.
This shall be a challenge.
Is there an internet cafe in Hell?
- No, do you need to use the internet?
- [Narrator] I may need
to use the internet.
- So you can just sign up to our WiFi.
- [Narrator] The WiFi on my
BlackBerry wasn't gonna help,
since Instagram doesn't
have a BlackBerry app.
So I hooked up the camera
to my new friend, Vaughn's Windows PC.
I'm gonna import them all to her computer.
I have no idea where these are going.
Then, I got to Googling.
Here, wait.
This seems like a hack.
I finally figured out a way.
A Google Chrome trick for developers
that lets you force your web browser
to be like a phone's web browser.
- That one's cute.
- Which one, this one?
- [Vaughn] Yeah, that one's cute too.
- [Narrator] Yeah, that one's good.
Hello from Hell.
I did it.
Challenge complete.
I feel pretty good.
I'm also starving.
Challenge three.
Review lunch on Yelp.
Its slim pickings on restaurants in Hell,
so I opted for the Hell Hole Bar,
and I ordered a local favorite.
So I'm gonna be eating the Patsy.
Patsty.
Patsy?
What is it called?
- [Man] Pasty.
- [Narrator] This is called a pasty.
This is a Michigan delicacy.
I'm eating a pasty and it
looks like a cross between
chicken pot pie and an empanada.
It's really good.
No posting my review was
well, not really possible.
There was very little 3G
service in the restaurant.
Like, the browser will load
but I can't really search
on the BlackBerry either.
The bigger issue was that
the BlackBerry 5 browser
was so slow to load images and the site,
and yes the iPhone 4 was out in 2010,
but I still had a BlackBerry.
It was only hours later,
while sitting on the plane back home,
that I was able to log in and post it.
Challenge complete.
Kinda.
Don't get me wrong, most of
my day in Hell was, hell.
Am I even in the photo?
But in many ways, it ended
up being like heaven.
I don't even want to take a photo of this.
It's that good.
It was nice remembering
how we used to do things,
like navigate the world with our brains
or ask people to take photos of us.
Best of all, it was nice to
remember when social media feeds
were just on computers
and unable to distract
us everywhere we are.
I'm back from Hell, and here it is.
I've made it.
My iPhone.
Would I do it again?
Hell no.
(upbeat music)
Greetings from Hell, Mom.